don't believe anything when this diet  helped my autoimmune disorder like fixed  me i was like  okay  what like that's a thing that can happen  well what else does the medical  community not know if you can treat some  of these things with diet for some  people so then i stopped believing in  that  and then it was like well what about the  government  isn't real right and then the media when  that happened to my dad i was like okay  so the media is a lie and it was like  three kind of pillars  that i believed in just crumbled and i  was like well then is anybody  who says they know what they're talking  about do they actually know and then it  turns out like most people who sound  like they know what they're talking  about also don't know what they're doing